okay call the meeting to order us uh
what is this fiscal committee welcome
all
and uh
i hope you have uh not has had not
had as long days as your house members
have over the last uh
three days so um
we did finish up at nine o'clock last
night that's why we're all here smiling
and
we're
looking forward to uh
the things on the agenda today
uh the first item on the agenda is the
uh acceptance
of the minutes of february 18th 2022
are there any corrections additions
changes
seeing none could i have a motion so
moved second second
senator daniels
and senator gaida
okay
all those in favor please raise your
hand
okay
eight in favor and one abstention
um
is there anyone that is interested in
taking um
the tabled item off the table
okay seeing none we will move on to
the audit topic recommendation
uh
from the letter from uh
senator reagan
and the
the audit that
is being asked to be approved
is um
efficiency and effectiveness of the
weatherization assistance program
uh as i understand it we need one vote
to approve this
so uh if there is uh anybody have any
objections
okay seeing none then um
tracy will
vote
yes
okay
right
madam chair
on the previous item um that was tabled
22-0-23
uh
would you share with us your
understanding of uh the status of that i
know it's tabled but i is do we know if
the department is is working on
addressing any of the concerns we had
yes
okay they are working on the rules
all right okay
all right um
you ready
all set okay
uh are there any items to come off the
consent calendar
okay just a minute
okay
oh oh let's do the whole everything
off of number nine i would like to
remove one one seven
and one one six
there's no one seven there's yeah nine
and ten sorry
no
which ones
off of item tab nine one one six
and tab ten one one seven page three
okay
okay thank you
are there any others
i i had some but i think representative
emerick has a punch list that yeah
yes
would you mind
madam chair the the items take taken off
in pre-fiscal meetings are
tab seven
two two oh nine eight
tab seven two two one hundred
uh tab nine
two two zero eight eight
tab nine two two zero nine nine
tab nine two two one one three tab nine
two two one one six
and tab ten two two one one seven
okay
all right uh can we have a vote to
remove these from the consent calendars
area
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
all right
so here we go man i'm sure we need a
vote now to approve all the ones that
are still on the consent
yes
could i have a motion to approve
the remainder of the items on the
consent calendar
senator rosenwald second
senator gaida
okay
and we need a roll call okay
this roll call for the balance of the
consent calendar representative edwards
yes
bert faucis
representative erf yes
representative walner
senator daniels yes
senator gray yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes
representative umberger
yes
madam chair the vote is nine zero okay
with a vote of nine to zero
the remainder of the items on the
consent calendar are approved
okay the first item that was uh taken
off the consent calendar
was 22098
from the department of education
for the record frank edelblut
commissioner of education
kelly rambo administrator for nutrition
programs and services
okay
um
okay um
the question that we had on this is
we're not exactly sure what this
transportation
part of this is all about
and
how are we
we just don't understand it it's not
we're not opposed to it we just don't
understand
how and what
is going on
so let me try and clarify that for you
and otherwise kelly can lean in on some
of the details as well
but basically we've received an
additional
source of funds from the federal
government
for our food and nutrition programs
to be able to support our food programs
throughout the state
in some of the additional costs that
they have incurred as a result of some
of the supply chain issues that have
happened in the across the country so
the difficulty in terms of getting uh
you know
food and supplies to the school to be
able to do it maybe they have to pay
expedited charges or they've got
additional costs associated with that
and so these funds will essentially
other than a small part be passed
through
to the districts to be able to support
the increased cost associated with
supply chain you know constraints that's
it
okay so
basically
the schools will ask for reimbursement
for these extra charges
thank you for your question so
there is a certain amount five thousand
dollars that gets disbursed to every sau
and then the remaining amount the
remaining amount
is dispersed based on the
meal counts from onion21
and the schools can opt
in for this and they or they can not
choose to take the funds and obviously
that would
change the amount that the and the
formula that that each school would get
to okay so it's based on meals served
correct okay
you know other than the five thousand
dollar flat fee that everybody gets
there any further questions
i have a tangential question if i may
certainly
uh
thanks for coming in mr commissioner i i
started a conversation with dhhs a
couple fiscal committees ago i had a
constituent call me up she works in a
nearby school district
and she
hammered me as good as i've been
hammered in a long time
about the extra burden
that the schools were bearing in order
to keep up with all the covid19
reporting
and
and i think that's primarily a
department of health and human services
task that's going to the schools
but i i just wanted to make you you
aware of it and ask you
if if you were aware of the schools
complaining about what feels to them as
a truly excessive workload around covid
reporting and can i just clarify you
saying specific to food and nutrition
programming or broadly no this is
tangential it's completely different
it's it's about covid
reporting i'm just using the fact that
you're up here on the nutrition to ask
you about something you're completely
unprepared for no actually i'm i'm quite
prepared for that so it's no problem at
all i because there was a significant
amount of reporting that was taking
place from our schools associated with
cases and contact racing
over time that has come down and on
february 23rd with the
update of the recommendations by public
health around some of the coveted
protocols
the amount of reporting by the schools
has been substantially reduced
and so there is some reporting that
continues but a significant amount of
that has been that burden has been taken
away from them
thank you for the sidebar i just asked
because the constituent was so fired up
yeah yep so i think we've taken care of
much of that thank you
okay are there any further questions
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
we need a motion
trying to get done very quickly yes i
am to approve
senator daniels second
sec
okay well
you know these official these official
things you know what do i know okay
well the clerk please call the roll roll
call on 22-098
representative edwards yes book vote
chess representative irf yes
representative walner
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator guida yes senator rosenwald yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is nine to zero
vote is nine to zero the motion passes
we now move to fis22100
which is uh requesting uh
54 plus in
federal cares act funding so
um
my question on this is that
i had thought
that all cares act money
had to have been allocated by
31 december
and so i was just
a little confused
as to
what was going on with the cares money
care exact money sure so i do believe
that that applied to the cares act funds
that were um appropriated through gopher
but there were many cares act funds that
were appropriated directly to the
department through that bill
and with this grant it is good until
september of 22.
so it and the dates of when the grants
expired from the cares act depended on
where the funding
where the funding was granted to and
this one was directly to the department
it was not through gopher
okay
representative edwards
it's kind of a two-part question i'll
ask it in one
um it says that this is to support the
survey and certification activities
and i was i was just curious if you
could characterize
what all goes into the survey and then
on the certification piece
what what what utility does that
certification serve does it authorize
receipt of funds from something or
why bother with the certification
you for the record my name is melissa
since here i'm the chief legal officer
for the department of health and human
services and i oversee the bureau of
licensing and certification uh relative
to this survey and certification the
question that you just had
arms and inspecting all aspects
of quality and care that's provided to
residents that live in nursing homes so
it's it's it's every aspect of medical
treatment
it's all aspects of the environment food
service every everything that they
possibly could be receiving treatment or
care for at the nursing home so these
surveyors go in and do that
the in doing so if they found them in
compliance of with cms regulations they
then are certified that facility becomes
certified
to provide services to medicare
recipients and medicaid recipients so
that's what the certification is for
so
follow-up
follow-up so what would be the impact if
um if they didn't get a certification
if they did not get their certification
they could lose all medicare funding and
not be able to provide services to
medicare recipients
could i have a motion to accept fis 22
100.
i'd
like to make a motion we accept 22 100.
okay represent
and rep senator rosenwald seconds
will the clerk call the roll we'll call
22 100 representative edwards yes
court votes yes representative irf yes
representative walner
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald
representative umberger yes
madam chair of the vote is 9-0
and with a vote of nine to zero fis 22
passes
okay
um
i see that thank you very much
okay
we're gonna
we're gonna go off on something else
right now
there's still dhs yes no no no no
no i didn't forget about it
he wasn't here
okay
um
this is a perfect place to bring up our
friend from das
mr arlinghaus
commissioner arlinghaus
at our last meeting
promised us that
by this meeting he would have hired his
three temporary positions for
working to
gain
employees in the state
so that's my first question is how are
we doing on that
uh well but
well so at our i'm gonna i'm gonna
take issue
not really but
i said give me a month
not a month from the date we were
speaking but a month from when we had
permission
right so uh our meeting was february
18th
the governor and council approval which
is required for this item
was march 9th
i can't post a position before march 9th
so
um we did a whole lot of work between
the council between this meeting and the
council meeting on the presumption and
normally i don't let people do work on
this presumption if it requires fiscal
and governor and council approval just
keep your shirt on until they both
approve
because that
because you know who knows what happens
at governor and council obviously you're
a very reasonable wonderful body
and um
but them who knows um and and they're a
reasonable wonderful body too for the
record if somebody's taking notes
um
so that meeting was march 29th we won't
put that in the minutes thank you i
appreciate that
so that meeting was march 9th and we
posted the position on march 10th
so which is pretty good i think i mean i
suppose theoretically we could have
gotten it up that afternoon but that's
silly um
position postings in the state process
require they be posted internally for a
period of time um typically five
business days was yesterday um
and uh we are likely to
extend the posting although evaluate
what we've so far but extend the posting
externally for five days
um days it might be seven days there's a
it's a standard work unit and it might
be seven days because it's five business
days um
at which point we have uh i actually
asked somebody to pull this for me
wednesday
so there are three positions we've
received four applications
um
there are one or two of them that may or
may not certify they're reviewing it to
make sure that they do the certification
process is
moderately cumbersome in the state
system
which is why we're probably going to go
external but we have in the meantime
developed
a
recruiting and marketing plan
a general business plan including
metrics and goals uh there is position
work underway pulling positions across
state government and vacancy rates
um to figure out uh which positions that
we're going to target first um i would
describe that as underway but the the
woman the the analyst doing that work
for us carolyn russell happens to be her
name
is fairly far advanced on that when we
talked about it a week ago
she seemed pretty clear on on at least
about half the positions they're going
to look at so i would expect that we
will
have hired all three positions
within a month
of the governor and council meeting
okay so you're tricking me i i'm really
trying hard too yes yeah i i i got it
okay so next month
in april next month i i'll actually have
names for you okay
so but
and it's important i know i know my
opening was a little bit silly but
it's important to note that
just because those three bodies have not
been hired doesn't mean that a lot of
work isn't being done by people who
already have too much on their plate and
so you know this is this has been
prioritized and is being and is being
worked on um i mean frankly not just by
you know uh carolyn is a very
personality
she was instead of the rest of the
department because of the importance of
this but she has she has three other
major projects that i'm constantly
harassing her about um and the director
of personnel is directly involved on
this herself and everybody else the only
person not directly involved on it is me
i just ask them what they're doing and
they tell me
okay um one of our concerns and the
reason i asked you to come up now
is because we have the
department of justice
looking for
an employee
and we have
was it hhs
oh the department of business and
economic affairs looking for three
people
and
so that's
four
additional
part-time people
and
the the concern that we have
is that
our vacancy rate which i guess you had
provided to us you know is this is just
on
full-time people
was at 18
and i don't know that we know what our
vacancies are on these
part-time positions or not part-time but
temporary positions
and so
[Music]
i would venture to say over the last
six months or so we've probably
approved
25 or 30 and maybe more uh
part-time
i keep using that word temporary
positions
um
we have no idea where those are on the
on the hiring process
because every person that talked to us
told us that if we didn't have these
temporary positions we couldn't do the
work
and so
is the work stopped
are we able to
you know you just said that even though
you don't have these people the work is
still going on
but
that didn't seem to be the feedback
that
at least i was getting from the other
agencies
well i i hate to say that it's
complicated but oh i know it is but i'm
going to um
so there are a couple things first of
all you you uh mr kane nicely provided
me the sheets so this sheet you know
their their vacancy rate is about 18
statewide is much higher among class 59
than it is among class 10s right your
your full-time permanent positions are
is lower than that
the the nature of a class 59 is it's
going to be higher because it's approved
it takes a while to find somebody when
you're in a tight market it takes a long
time to find somebody
why do people ask for a position even
though they have a vacancy because it's
the state and you have to you have so
i'm going to use an example i have a
vacant internal auditor and i made a
decision for about three years not to
fill it on purpose even though it's
funded because we had a lapse target we
had to hit and i needed to use that to
hit the laps target i had to carefully
look at and not fill let's say for the
sake of argument you had said no last
month um
and you can't hire anybody to do
recruitment and i'd go oh you know what
i'm going to use the internal auditor to
do recruitment you're not allowed to
that would be illegal i'm not i'm not
actually i can temporarily assign people
to do things but i can't hire some i
would hire somebody with an audit
background because i have to have an
audit background that sjd has to be
approved the salary is set based on
those duties and you you can't like i
couldn't have a building service worker
being paid as an internal auditor
it's it's not permissible in the system
so i can't use that position for that
some are more fungible some are less
fungible
it's very true on part-timers too you
know i have i have right now in our
department 48 or 49 vacancies among
building service workers
which are
mostly part-time unlikely to ever go
down because
you know why would you clean toilets for
the state when you could work at dunkin
donuts
and it's uh and that's a thing
it doesn't help me in some other areas
so some of when when an agency asks you
for funding is going to be based on that
that they can't they have positions that
they can't repurpose for that
in addition to that
for some of the grant funding and things
like that
um i want to hire somebody into a
position that is a class 59 not a class
because it is going to go away when the
funding goes away and i don't want to
create a permanent position i can't
create a permanent position based on
temporary funding and so
um
you know there's an element where this
is sort of a nice thing for the employee
too that you're hiring someone in and
you you're basically saying to them at
the front end i hope you understand and
i'm being upfront with you that this is
based on a grant it's why it's called a
full-time temporary if you do a good job
and we keep getting the grant we'll keep
you but it might go away in two years
and your position will go away in two
years so some of it is about what
position is what position
um
and and you look at it
there's also no agency i suspect sitting
behind us who thinks
i'm planning an 18 vacancy rate for the
rest of it
everybody's trying to fill positions
obviously i mean you know that
and um and they think
everybody thinks that next week i'm
going to get lucky
and you know next week this is actually
going to happen and that the resumes
that came in this week are not
indicative of what's going to come in
next week that suddenly something's
going to happen and
all those 26 year olds who have decided
they don't want to work anymore
they're going to wake up and decide they
want to work and and i don't know that
it's all 26 year olds but my
understanding is that's a that's a
demographic that's hurting us right now
and so
you're pushing and you're pushing and
you're pushing you know we have a we
have a we have some areas where we've
had a lot of luck in filling positions
and i and i think to myself
you know what hiring problem and then we
have a couple of areas where we're you
know computer profession professionals
for example
where
wow this is really hard so i think
that's some of what goes on with
positions if that helps at all
senator rosenwald thank you
at a previous fiscal meeting and i don't
know if it was the last one or maybe the
one before that
we
were asked to approve
eight
non-classified positions
for hampstead hospital
and appropriate some
funds i think it was and we did that
but now there's a piece of legislation
moving through the senate
that wants to
add
six
unclassified positions and doesn't
appropriate any money
so
i think the money we appropriated in
fiscal would pay for those
six positions but it feels to me like we
over appropriated money and over created
positions because what happens to the
eight
non-classified positions
we created so i can talk about the
generics of
that
admittedly very unusual and and rarely
used process but i suspect the specifics
are maybe we could ask karen rounds to
come up oh here she
good morning karen rounds to financial
officer health and human services um
so these six
non-classified positions that were
created with that arpa item as charlie
mentioned was a little bit of an unusual
situation right we are purchasing
hampstead and need to stand up some of
those positions
even before we can get the operating
budget to you those positions are
currently posted
those six positions are intended to be
replaced by the six unclassified
positions so those six non-classified
positions would be eliminated
and if it it's you know makes
people more comfortable to put right
into
the senate bill that these positions
will replace those positions that the
department is completely agreeable to
that
um the reason that the unclassified
positions are so important is that the
non-classified positions don't have a
salary
grading system they are positions that
are authorized by the governor and so we
need to have the unclassified positions
to go through the jcec process and
assure that we set the salaries at the
appropriate place now we have a pretty
good sense of where they will land based
on other positions in the department but
we want to make sure that those
positions are established appropriately
through that unclassified process and
that the salaries are established
appropriately so that's the reason that
we've set those up now because we cannot
create an unclassified position
without going through the legislative
process so we are creating a
non-classified position until the
unclassified positions are created
now i know that there was some
suggestion that
perhaps we could wait until the budget
process to create the unclassified
position
i think the um the reason that i
wouldn't suggest that uh is that the
non-classifi the unclassified positions
once they're created will need to go
through the jcec process which can take
several months and so if those are
created now in this legislative session
sometime in the next fiscal year 23 we
will be able to move those people into
an unclassified position eliminate the
non-classified positions and then they
will be established and properly
budgeted in the 2425 budget
as far as whether we've double budgeted
the funding for those no we won't be
double budgeting them we will make sure
that
when we bring forward the operating
budget there is a balance between what
we expect than
the unclassified positions to be
completed by jcec in the operating
budget and we won't be double budgeting
those positions
you have a follow-up
no problem thank you that is helpful and
i'm sure you'll help us
write an amendment to senate bill 430
but aren't those positions
the positions we created here were
non-clinical
and the bill's positions i think are
clinical i don't believe so they're
intended to replace those six positions
i don't think they're specific in the
bill as to what the position titles are
if that
corrects yes so um but yes we will get
you some language to add to that
excellent i'm sure senator daniels and
gaia and i will appreciate that thank
you madam chair
okay
are there any other
other questions for uh commissioner
arlinghaus
okay
thank you madam chair
um
mr arlinghaus i i i'm looking at um a
document you may have seen but it's
essentially a spreadsheet of about 49
departments and sub departments for
which we have total and vacant full-time
classified funded positions
it's something that mr cain has handed
out to us yes okay so um
back in the old days when i did some
manpower analysis i i kept track of the
space availability uh next to it
and and i i'm just curious
uh what your process is for making sure
that we have
space to put these folks if we hire them
all i you know
like do you keep a red yellow green kind
of
process where
we're red if we just don't have a future
place to put them and green if
everything's okay or how do you do it we
so we typically
uh
haphazardly is probably a good answer um
it's not literally true but um
space is assigned in buildings and and
generally the way uh life works is uh
the occupying army keeps the space that
they've been assigned unless somebody
has proof that they don't need it i mean
once uh once the department lays claim
to a land area it's sometimes it's hard
to take it away from them we we will
make adjustments and it statutorily that
is my authority and somebody said to me
you can just kick them out of the
building and i'm like yeah and then i
got to find somewhere for them to go and
and you take space away from somebody
and they completely freak out because
it's there's nothing more
traumatic than moving your desk right
and so we're so we're careful about it
and so generally speaking
um you know if you're if you're i'm
going to use examples in the annex the
department of agriculture has these
rooms
in this space
and at some point if they start getting
positions thrown at them in the budget
something might come up and we might
have to look at and go you know what
we're probably going to have to move
abandoned property for the treasury over
here and move them here and kind of
create a little bit of room for them um
but until that happens where there's an
issue we kind of let it go we don't we
we wouldn't say we wouldn't keep such
perfect track of their vacancies to say
that you know based on what we're
looking at you've got six open positions
and you have desk space for them i'm
gonna take uh uh human rights commission
and move them in on you so we so we try
not to do that it's rare it's what's
typically the case is that an agency has
enough space for the people they have
and they may do some internal moving
around to make that work somebody who
thinks he or she is entitled to an
office not that anyone's entitled um is
in a cubicle or vice versa sometimes
it's like you know i got an office
because nobody was using it
and uh and sometimes that happens but um
it's sort of moving around we we're
doing some work in the annex or
preliminary work now but eventually
it'll be chaos
um
and we were moving people around and i
had to take for example judicial council
you guys see sarah periodically we had
to move them somewhere there weren't
there were only a few places to move
them because we were doing asbestos
remediation where they were
and so
actually my office and my assistant's
office is where they are now
and i'm in a supply closet
it's not a supply closet it's larger
than that and there's a window so it's
not really but that didn't stop the
terry path and the attorney general from
mocking me last week from my office but
it's perfectly lovely but we did that
because all right this works you know
this is open and we can put the copier
here instead of here and and you know
there's some fire suppression sensors on
the wall but you know i wouldn't mind
knowing when there was a fire and so you
do some of that um to sort of make it
out so we we keep regular track and when
the budget passes
you know somebody in joe's team does a
does a position summary on on where
positions were added
and we keep track of that
and then we work with the people
our plant and property people will work
directly with the agency to say you know
what's going on and what and you know
because sometimes they'll know
they'll know when the men's room leaks
before we do
so
um
and we'll fix that okay thank you i know
that sounds really organized it is
some of us have done that for a living
anyhow
i guess that uh
this vacancy rate for new hampshire that
was put together by you initially
correct yes okay
um can we add to this
temporary
positions that so this this sheet that
i'm holding up
um
oh there's a camera i keep forgetting
there's a camera um is it says full-time
classified funded positions at the top
and this is class 10 and 59 and i can
get you data that breaks it down by the
tens and the tens of the full-time
permanent 59 i mean you're all the
budget people you you're you're actually
the people who know this um the uh and
the full-time temps and i can break it
down by those two and you'll see the one
is slightly lower because it's the tens
and the 59s are higher in part because
there's a long occasionally a long lag
after they're created before they're
filled okay thank you i i didn't realize
i don't think any of us realize that
this included both
oh i'm sorry yes okay
so the reason i know it included both
because so
i'm sure you know that i didn't do this
myself
um actually the person who did it is uh
carolyn russell working with fdm and i
took our department and tried to
validate it to i thought all right what
do i think our vacancy rate is and i and
i went through it and i'm like wait a
minute why am i getting a different
number and then it's like oh she's
including the 59s okay here i am and
then once i got there i thought okay
this works because it you know i know
from hiring that it's actually right
i mean it's you know technically out of
date every time we hire somebody right
is it right
not much
okay well i thank you so
you'll be back
next month
i'm here every month whether you want me
to be or not yeah statutorily you're
right except you were late today so well
i was at ways and means just for the
record
i have one more question for you oh
sorry
ollie thank you mr arlingham
so one of the things i couldn't find was
the vacancy rate for part-time positions
you know i have lists of part-time
positions is that something that you try
it isn't and let me explain why um
an agency
if it wanted to could sort of do a
part-time vacancy rate but it's sort of
for this reason when you do budgets
uh part-time positions are placed in
class 50 and you're not assigning
positions so so the so the budget that
you do is budgeted by position i mean
literally if you go in the background of
the system there's a there's a position
module and there's a there's a specific
number of positions assigned to very
specific things and those positions are
created in the system so they exist
part-time functionally what you do is
you say to uh to uh to an accounting
unit
here's a hundred grand
for part-time workers
and
there's a basis for that the agency in
developing the budget will do we'll do
um sheets in the background to say well
you know fred makes this and tony makes
we do it obviously every accounting unit
for building service workers who are
mostly part-time
and there's like you know you know you
know beth made 12 grand last year and
and patty made 14-6 and
and you know kim you go down that list
um but technically i could hire two
people at six grand instead of one
person at 12. okay you're what you're
doing is appropriating money to me to
spend on part-time workers as many or as
few as i want
technically non-classified is the same
thing right we cr you created
non-classified positions well on the
budget they think of the governor's
office which is really where the only
non-classified positions are or were and
will be again
you just give him a chunk of money and
he can pay anybody whatever he wants
because because it's a week because it's
a you know it's because it's a political
office not a not an administrative
office right and so
i said to him once that you could this
is when i worked there i said you could
pay one employee 500 000 if you wanted
to not telling you which one it should
be
but um
but that's technically true right it
would be weird but it's true and part
time is the same way that there's a
part-time money allocated not a position
so anything i told you would be vague
a follow-up
so when you create
when we create these part-time positions
in fiscal
how do we ever know if they're
getting filled and doing their what
they're supposed to be doing
um i mean
in theory when you're when you're going
through and this typically happens right
at the at the division level in finance
when you're going through the finance
process there's a lot of reporting a lot
of it you wouldn't necessarily know you
don't necessarily need to know on on the
part-time money in particular because i
i think the thought process in the in in
the past had always been
i'm going to authorize you to do this
i'm going to authorize you to do it with
part-time workers
and and the distinction really is that
we're not paying benefits right it's not
it's not really more complicated than
that and because of that i'm not really
worried that you might be paying
somebody
too much money or out of whack because
they're they are going to be created
they are going to have an sjd in the
system they are going to be part of that
so they'll be
they'll match the system that way
i'm i just want to know if you're going
to get it done and it'd be too much to
manage
so you've agreed to less oversight but
you can always ask
okay so i'm not worried about the money
i mean i know it should be but that's
not what i'm talking about i'm sure
about the job getting done and these a
lot of these arpa positions are coming
in that way and then we never hear
well some of these
some of these positions in that big
spreadsheet are part time maybe the
wrong thing but
so um
i mean we can get back to you
periodically on on position counts but
but if you think about the vacancy sheet
you have for example
you know the the
17.7 you don't know exactly which
position and and which person does it so
i think it's hard i think any time you
know with any project uh you know i
think we're in a system where
um any commissioner director or state
employee would feel like a question from
fiscal is one they're required to answer
and and that would happen and um
i know our sense on our arpa stuff is
that is that there will be a not day of
reckoning what's the right term for that
an accounting that we have to do for it
right that we have to come forward and
say this happened
and
um
you know if i have a position
i'm going to try like hell to fill it
i mean it's it's you know i have a i
have a i have a
you know 400 people well vacancies so
300 and some who are working their tails
off and struggling right to get you know
i talk to the cleaner on my floor every
night and and we have conversations
about she hates the cleaning product we
buy she thinks it's colored water we
need something with acid in it um i know
more about cleaning products than i did
five years ago but
because she's trying really hard to get
stuff done and she's like well we don't
do that anymore on wednesdays because i
don't have time
and so if i got a position
you know there's nobody in state
government who doesn't want to fill it
period
okay thank you very much and we will
look forward to
hearing from you in april as will i
and uh
i i really really appreciate it because
this is something that obviously
concerns all of us that we are approving
so many
temporary positions
to do specific work
and we have no clue
as to whether or not it's
getting done so we're we're from my just
so you know from our standpoint we're
very eager about this too this is this
is an area where i i think and and i
speak for everybody probably in hr in
the state but um we think we can really
make a difference in helping people it's
a it's a struggle for everybody probably
it's a struggle for every business in
the state right right now but it's a
struggle for everybody and and
you know the pitch pitching arp on us
the idea
was to try to help people and it's and
we and you know the thought was you know
where can we make a difference for
agencies and you know nobody sitting
behind me is going to
raise his or her hand if i say raise
your hand if you found it easy to hire
so so we're very optimistic that
good things will happen
okay thank you
and the reason that i asked commissioner
arlinghaus to come up is because
although we have uh basically approved
already 22 104 for the department of
justice they are looking to hire
a temporary full-time position
and so
i think
we have a better understanding hopefully
of uh of what's going on out there
and um you know don't be surprised over
the next several months if we don't
continue to ask questions about
vacancy rates
okay
uh the next item is um
[Music]
fis22
tab nine
pardon
okay
welcome back
thanks
uh
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair um i think this
is going to be
an easy one on
in the middle of the first paragraph on
the second page
it says uh that the activity supported
under this award will include and here's
the key word continued
development of streamlined approaches
for the clutch blah blah blah blah so my
question there is
it sounds like some streamlining has
already taken place and we're going to
continue to streamline
can you tell us
how much
you know how much more efficient has
this first year made us and and what do
we think the potential for streamlining
is in the second year
sure good morning uh for the record i'm
ian what i'm the deputy director for the
division of public health services um
you know in looking at our processes
we're obviously always trying to be more
efficient
in both accepting information with our
internal systems and how we aggregate
that information
the volume of data that we've received
you know throughout the pandemic has
obviously exceeded anything that we have
historically had to take on so
you know
i can't speak to specific tactics we'll
be taking uh moving forward but we are
always looking at how we utilize staff
how we utilize systems and how we accept
information you heard earlier from from
the commissioner of education that our
the information we're getting is
evolving how both how much and the exact
data that we're receiving and so we'll
continue to look at as we receive data
reports how we accept them and how we
use that data for our public dashboards
and some of that de-identified data that
continues to be useful for the public
so so i pulled that out because it just
seems like it's an inherently hard thing
to have performance metrics around
how much development have we done how
much more do we have to do it's kind of
hard to say so i'm just i'm just
curious if if how you're monitoring or
measuring it so you feel like you're
being successful in this area yeah so
you know we receive both case reports i
mean this uh item specifically refers to
travelers health
and i'm speaking more broadly when i
speak to data we receive case reports on
a daily basis through various forms and
you know our intent is to get through
that data aggregated and produce public
information as quickly as possible
we have at various times the pandemic
you know had varying success just given
the volume of cases that have come in so
you know our expectation going forward
given the uh
you know lessening of cases in the
community would be that we will be able
to continue to meet that
kind of semi-regular deadline either
daily or or semi-daily to be able to
report a full case count and completed
reports
we don't have a clock on ourselves in
terms of an exact timeline to report
that data we try to be as efficient
efficient as possible with the staff
that we have
obviously relative to the case counts
that we're we're receiving
as i was reading the department's
set of materials here one trend that
i've seen
and i don't know miss rounds if you're
responsible for this but i really
appreciate that i think you all are
anticipating the kinds of questions
we're going to ask and so i i just think
in this document and the subsequent ones
i i just appreciate that you guys are
putting in the extra work to be clear on
on what what you're doing so so thank
you you're welcome and the credit for
that definitely goes to the program
directors and the finance directors
okay i i have one question unless
someone else has a question
okay yes go ahead please senator daniels
thank you could you get clarification uh
under the requested action and they have
the word mandated
when it says protecting the health of
travelers and communities and global
mobile world project
as mandated
by by opera
is it i i'd like to understand how the
word
is used is that saying that arpa is
mandating
that we need to have this program or or
is it saying that you know that there's
a program and that
there's something within oppa that's
that tells
how it's going to be
used if it's accepted right
yeah so thank you for the question so
this is a language that we've used and
has been used throughout the pandemic
with funds accepted through arpa so
should we accept this funding and
activate this program we're mandated to
utilize it for the intentions of the
program as outlined in the rescue plan
act so you know we're not mandated to
activate the program we're certainly
mandated to use the money as intended by
the federal law thank you
we also had a discussion in
our group
and um
as we understand it you go out and apply
for the money
and then they either agree or disagree
and so really what we're doing is
we are required to spend the money
for what
you have asked for
or what they have
sent or whatever
so
from my perspective
it would
it would seem to me that it is
the the mandating is for the fact that
you got the money and you're spending it
and to me mandating means they told you
you had to go and get it
which is not the way i understand the
program work so
from my perspective i would prefer a
different word like required
and not because it's not man you know
the only reason it's mandated is because
you went and asked for the money and you
have to spend it so
you know you don't they don't
when you come in for other
non-arpa money i don't think you use the
term mandated
i think
you know you
so
if we can certainly make that adjustment
you know if that's if that's okay you
know it
just it's one of those things that
sometimes get people's hair on the back
of their neck up
okay
are they oh yes i do have one
question on
this and
not that it's a huge amount of money
but it says you're going to purchase the
canvas software
and
[Music]
since this is all
contract
i didn't understand why
the department needed to purchase
the canvas software yeah so the staff
member identified in this item
you know may have the need to develop
some kind of quick graphics for our
social media accounts or reporting or
other kind of public information and the
canva account which i believe is about
120 annual license will allow them to do
that on demand without
consulting so this is not necessarily
just for this program is that correct
you're just financing it up out of this
program i hope well we would certainly
utilize it for traveler health
information that we disseminate over
social media and otherwise um
it would certainly be extensible i mean
the license isn't limited to just this
work
okay
man i'm sure ma'am move to um that we
ought to pass on 22-088
all right do i have a second
senator rosenwald thank you
by the way maybe i'll come over and
attempt to use your canvas software it
sounds interesting please do
pardon me
oh i just said please oh please do okay
go ahead
roll call on zero eight eight
representative edwards yes
clerk votes yes representative erf yes
representative walner
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
representative umberger
yes
madam chair the vote is nine to zero
uh thank you very much on a vote of nine
to zero
uh fis2208
is
passed
okay now we turn to
fis-22099
oh we're in the same tab tab
did you give me permission not yet
okay um
you have a senator edward
thank you representative edwards you
have a question thank you madam chair
and this this is sort of similar to the
um the mandate question are we using the
right term
and i'm glad we had that conversation
because this was the first time i noted
it on this
but on the on the second page
there's another word here that i i think
may be improperly used in the context
and that's the word infrastructure
it says on the second sentence towards
the end it says we're going to build and
maintain infa
infection prevention
infrastructure necessary necessary to
support law
so
uh what
to me the word infrastructure means
we're going to buy something that's
going to be persistent and everything i
read in this makes us feel like it's
just temporary or transitory and it
is we're going to get a temporary
capacity perhaps but i i the word
infrastructure jumps out can you can you
talk to that yeah so so in addition you
know i think you make a good point
certainly the resources in terms of
people would be kind of transitory or
temporary public health education we
consider a fairly durable good and part
of you know the fabric of public health
in the community and in these facilities
in terms of infection control management
and just
information around covid19 and other
transmissible diseases so you know we
consider that an infrastructure
investment in these facilities that they
would get on a long-term basis but you
know certainly point taken about kind of
the physical assets and and commitment
that way
all right
yeah sometimes uh
budgeteers fall into
using words that's being funded
currently and infrastructure is a good
hot word to fund but if we could be
precise there that'd be better for me
but um all right so
it says in the second paragraph that
you're monitoring the indicators and so
if i were to ask i'm not asking but if i
were to ask for a list of the indicators
that you that you monitor could you
produce such a list
yeah so in you know putting forth a
similar program over the course of the
the omicron search and what we saw this
past winter you know we monitor a number
of patients you know patient throughput
and the ability to care for individuals
how many people we can get out of
hospitals efficiently to ensure the
health care system is functioning so we
would have information like that
regarding what
this investment helped facilitate within
these
these facilities and then you know in
turn how they help the health care
system
all right thank you for the answers and
thank you madam chair
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
will you be able to include the veterans
home in this
if in this
capacity building work
public health so i actually don't have
that answer offhand
we have worked with both county
facilities and private facilities and
others
i don't have in front of me and i don't
have that knowledge in my head
unfortunately
okay could you please get that back to
us absolutely okay more than happy yeah
thank you just send it if you would to
uh
lba and they'll get it out because i
think that's a it's an extremely
important
uh
area
is there anything any
uh
representative earth
thank you madam chair
i have some sort of broad
questions about the effectiveness of
effectiveness of the program
i understand that
some some nursing homes didn't
choose to participate the reason being
that there's a fear that they get these
patients in
out of the hospitals with the strike
team then the strike team leaves and
then they still have the patience
so i'm curious as to how many nursing
homes participate in both county i mean
broken up county and private
and how cost effective has the program
been in terms of actually
getting patients out of the hospital
into nursing homes and then being able
to continue to provide service the
nursing's homes continue to be able to
continue to be able to provide services
those folks once the strike teams are
gone because i believe this is the
second or third
go around to this type of program
so i did uh receive your questions
earlier this morning and chatted uh
briefly with chris antonello as did ian
unfortunately she wasn't able to be here
this morning but she is preparing all
that information to provide to you
thank you you're welcome
okay
that'll be
we'll we'll all be interested in in
seeing that
okay uh are there any further questions
could i have a motion to accept fis
20 excuse me 99 yeah two two so moved
zero nine nine second
okay representative erf and
representative edwards
will the clerk please call the roll
roll call on
22-09 representative edwards yes clerk
votes yes representative erf yes
representative walner
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is 9-0
vote being nine to zero fis22-099
is approved
okay
we now move to fis22113
and that is in tab nine as well thank
you
uh
questions
i had a question i just need to get my
uh piece of paper out
you can come back to me if you're
willing
okay
uh represent earth
so few questions um
this runs through 2026 but i guess the
funding is only through this biennium
the the four million dollars or whatever
it is
i'm kind of curious is this going to be
a long term we're going to have this
huge space not going into the future or
is this kind of a temporary thing is
codeword related it seems like
like a lot of money for a big space
so we have thank you for the question so
we have
you know at this point a lot of durable
items ppe testing equipment durable
medical goods like ventilators
ventilator equipment on hand and we have
that on hand you know anticipating what
we've seen this past winter you know we
obviously don't know what the the future
holds in terms of covet 19 we are in a
very in a good place right now in terms
of case counts we do anticipate case
counts will increase in the future we
don't know to what level we don't know
on what frequency so you know the idea
of the stockpile of goods and this
warehouse is to have us have supplies on
hand that allow us to endure the same
breaks in the supply chain that we've
seen over the past two years obviously
in 2020 you know we're in a position
where we weren't able to get almost
anything we were getting kind of single
goods one at a time this winter we saw
the same you know challenges related to
gloves related to n95 masks so the
intent is to make sure that we can
continue to provide a continuity of
services to healthcare facilities to
schools to correctional facilities and
others you know to make sure that we
continue to be able to operate life as
normal here in new hampshire in terms of
you know long term past the five years
our intent would actually be to be
evaluating the space on an annual basis
um and that's included in the lease
i don't anticipate we would not have any
space before the end of five years and i
can't project you know past five years
obviously not anticipating where we'll
be with coven 19 or any other challenges
we may endure between now and then
but certainly it's a continuous
evaluation on our part of what is
necessary to you know to react to and be
prepared for
for future events
thank you
i have my paper now representative
edwards uh
thank you madam chair
so
so i had the same question um
about the long-term nature of the space
and and and it's a it's
all together
about 3.9 million dollars which just
feels like a lot of money for two street
addresses uh for a year um and so
uh i'm i'm guessing that because this
was
an urgent need
we we didn't go out for bid
and i i'd like you to confirm that and
could you tell us who the
the property owner is for this this
piece of property
i assume it's one owner because it's 19
and 23 terrell park drive in concord so
what i can tell you having been at the
emergency operations center when we
first procured uh
this space is that we did look at
several different spaces at the time
you're correct that it didn't go out to
bid because it was an emergency at that
point we had ppe coming in and needed a
place to put it um
but i can tell you that the price was
competitive i don't have the name of the
owner but i'd be happy to get you that
information
i i i'd appreciate it and and also if
you could give me some idea what the
ballpark is on the cost per square foot
for the rental sure is i i i i have no
clue how big these facilities are but
that just seems like a lot of money for
a year lease
yes we can get you that information okay
thank you thank you madam chair
are there any uh rep senator rosenwald
thank you
so if you're
gonna keep this space through the next
budget are you gonna be looking for
eight million dollars
for the next budget
uh potentially so that's something as
ian mentioned we'll be evaluating each
year
i believe the letter said by may first
of each year so that does allow us to
adjust the budget in the senate phase if
we needed to
based on what we would need going
forward but i expect over the next six
months we'll also have a better sense
whether we see
continued surges and and what they look
like and like ian said what the needs of
the based on the supply chain are so i'm
i'm confident that before we're
closing on a budget we'll have a pretty
good sense what is needed
yes please thank you
so you're storing ventilators there that
the state owns
or do
the hospitals own the ventilators and
you're just storing them
so
we have a variety of goods there so
in 2020 obviously getting ventilators
was extremely difficult and the federal
government out of the strategic national
stockpile distributed ventilators to the
states so we accepted
that equipment on behalf of new
hampshire and then
distributed to facilities for their
needs we have seen because you know some
ventilators and some ventilator parts
are not renewable uh they need
replacement or they need to be used you
know one one offs
per patient excuse me um
we have additional equipment all of
which actually was distributed during uh
this past winter surge some of that
equipment the hospitals may maintain for
ongoing needs you know based on the
demand that they've seen some of it will
take back and store again for
distribution should it be needed in the
future thank you thank you
if oh yes senator daniels
thank you karen did i hear you say that
it was expected in the next budget that
you would be asking for
for money for the storage potentially we
would of course always first look to any
federal funds that we might have
available to continue to pay for it um
as you know we haven't even started the
agency phase of the budget yet so it's
not something that i've you know sat
down and talked with anyone about but it
it's something we'll need to evaluate
okay follow-up yes uh so how do you
reconcile your your answer with the
statement that in the event these
federal funds become no longer available
general funds will not be requested to
support the program
so this request is only through the end
of this biennium so that is true for
this biennium
when it comes to the contract when it
goes to gnc that contract would look
differently
but with regards to this request for the
funding for the next for this biennium
we would not request general funds
so for clarification that statement then
only pertains to this biennium
not the total amount of time that the
federal funds are available
crick because you are approving the
financial you are approving us spending
these federal funds which we are saying
we will not replace with general funds
you're not approving the contract
we just provided information on what we
anticipate the contract looking like
okay thank you
and and it does say in here uh senator
daniels that
through december
on the
near the bottom of page two
because that's when the arpa money runs
out
i think
so
adam chair that's what i was talking
about but that's why i'm a little bit
confused because what i'm what i'm
hearing is that that statement that uh
that that uh no general funds will be
requested is only for this biennium
right but you're you're talking about a
date that is out in 26 and
yeah you know i'm just kind of curious
as to to what happens when
you know this one-time money drops off
and we've still got loads of stuff
that's stored
uh
how was you know what are we going to do
with it how is it going to be paid for
things like that if you're not asking
for general funds yes and we we out as
ian mentioned we absolutely plan on
evaluating this annually and if we did
need to reduce
what is being kept to reduce the space
that would require an entire plan which
we would have
uh
anyone else
yes
represent edwards i just want to um
say to you and you probably look at it
the same way i look at four million
dollars a year
as being more than half of what we would
want to spend on an adult dental
medicaid program and so
buying
renting space
and taking and doing direct health care
i i just want to keep our priorities
straight that we minimize
you know our investment and logistics
particularly when we're just renting
renters
understood
okay
are there any further questions okay i
have a question
i know you mentioned the what's it
called the federal strategic reserve
whatever it's called it's the strategic
strategic national stockpile okay thank
you
does the state have a requirement to
have a strategic stockpile so
so the strategic national stockpile
actually the it's part of a federal
program that requires us to be a conduit
should there be
you know a major biological event or
other event that requires us to
distribute certain supplies we have
other facilities around the state
pre-identified where we'd be able to
stage and actually distribute to people
in need of you know whatever it may be
medication or otherwise so we have a
space and this is something that
predates the pandemic as well we have a
requirement to have space available to
accept
that shipment so we don't actually have
to have anything on hand we just have to
be able to accept it from the national
program yeah the strategic national
stockpile does not obligate the state to
hold the stockpile okay but it does
obligate us to have a distribution
center
it obligates us to have the ability to
accept uh accept goods to be able to
distribute them okay
now
you may or may not know that i spent 28
years in
logistics
and so this is
a logistics question
what is your what are your inventory
procedures
and your in and outs
and replacement do you have a system or
are we just
doing something i don't know what
so that's a very good question thank you
so i don't want i don't want to say that
because i know as a logistician i never
did anything haphazardly so we we have
you know obviously the the pandemic
required us to stand up this capability
to a scale that we had not previously
executed in dhhs we used an existing
system called juvari um to manage our
inventory uh we have a full-time
logistics coordinator who has been a
part of our staff i believe the position
has been funded for about a decade
and that person is responsible for
maintaining that inventory they have
three contract staff currently
supporting them in terms of your point
about ins and outs you know
it is a question top of mind for us as
well in terms of turnover of the
equipment you know some of the equipment
does have expiration dates and we're
actively looking at those questions now
partnering with the hospitals you know
turning over equipment to them for their
use so that we don't have stale
equipment
yes so all the questions are certainly
in mind and we're actively pursuing them
as possible
because i certainly don't want to end up
in the situation that we did when
the first part you know covet
pandemic where the stuff that was in the
strategic stockpile was outdated broken
whatever else
and i just wanted to add to that we also
have to provide an annual inventory for
the act for formerly known as the kafir
to the department of administrative
services
can we do that as well you had a
question yes yes one additional question
please
i know that we have state buildings that
are vacant why can we not use those
buildings as opposed to
spending this money on renting
charlie
we don't have state buildings that are
vacant in that way
the state space that is habitable is all
habited
there are some buildings on the campus
for example that are relatively vacant
think of kent that's attached to the
back of main building but to give you an
idea of what kind of building it is when
i walked through it
when i started first became commissioner
the direction was don't look where
you're walking look at the floor because
you don't want to step on the holes and
and be careful before you take a step to
make sure it looks like it um it looks
like it'll hold
and the piles that look like bird
droppings and raccoon droppings are
so that building is vacant it's not
suitable for stockpiling medical
equipment
there are there's a there's a thought
people have about how we have lots of
lots of empty and vacant buildings
the state has since since representative
calaba was on from litchfield was on the
on the committee in the late 90s has
been aggressively looking at
redoing buildings for example that
campus there's nothing vacant anymore
that's that's structurally sound there
are some buildings are in the process of
being converted bancroft is the only
real example of this
where
yeah but it's not suitable for a for a
warehouse
we don't have warehouse space what we
typically do is is we convert anything
we have that somebody can go in we stick
somebody in because we're currently
renting
don't hold me to this number but
something like 250 000 square feet of
office space
around the city of concord so there so
there aren't really
vacant spots that anything could go in
when the during the pandemic i know i
don't know any of the details on this
because i i have very smart people who
worked on it and i don't know any of the
details but um
worked with hhs on finding warehouse
space and and we didn't have any of our
own we just didn't
like i i literally can't think of a big
room somewhere that we could stick stuff
no i was just questioning and bancroft
came to mind because we were out looking
at
space when we talked about the
psychiatric
hospital and
other things uh we got it regarding
mental health and i knew it wasn't being
used
i mean i'm not sure if it's uh
if it if it's not you say that it's not
appropriate i'm not sure
why it may be that it needs renovation
to it and then there's a question is
well should we maybe take the money that
we would be spending
on renting and put that into renovating
a building so that we've got something
that we can use
for something else when we're done using
it as a warehouse so i'm just just
trying to look at the other options and
and i think i think that's actually not
a not a bad thing to do at some point
look at that i it's it's a longer term
rather than shorter term that is to say
probably won't solve
needs in the first year or two but um
just at bancroft for an update because i
know there's a lot of interest in
bancroft because of the nature of that
building and and people who have been
to it and i don't know anybody's been in
it recently but
the last capital bud budget item secured
it from the weather right in a in a
building's lifespan it reaches a point
where
if you stop working on it it's going to
become like laconia let's say where the
question is how you tear it down not if
um and the
policymakers made a decision three years
ago to decide that we probably don't
want to tear it down so we fixed the
roof and we fixed a lot of the you know
things like caulking so that when you're
you know when i toured bancroft the
first time it was a rainstorm and and
the guys who were showing it to me
i remember doug burnham in particular
he had a he had a notebook with him and
he was excited because he uh aside from
knowing where all the ghosts are he now
knew where all the leaks were because it
was raining and he's like okay there's
one there and there's one there hang on
just say let me finish this let me
finish writing in the leaks before we
talk
and uh so we'll fix that but in terms of
like let's say you wanted to put a
psychiatric facility in there lots and
lots of millions of dollars to turn it
from
you know because there's you know
there's there's lead paint and there are
some holes but it's externally protected
to keep it from falling apart
thank you
okay thank you
certainly
thank thank you i i sort of was thinking
about senator daniel's question
i think i read
that it's the intent of the governor
to
destroy
um plow under
uh the sununu youth development center
when it gets emptied and and and that's
just a lot of building there that seems
to have uh repurposed potential
are we going to actually do a business
case analysis
on whether or not we can repurpose that
building versus just destroying it
can we get that information back to you
the uh director of dcyf isn't here today
and i think he would
like to be part of that conversation
that's fine
i don't think we're going to tear it
down this week
okay could i have uh are there any other
questions
all right could i have a motion please
oh i'm i'm sorry senator guida i didn't
see you thank you madam chair just based
on the last set of comments
would it be appropriate to do a uh
a tabling
until we can find out whether sununu
might be usable
i've toured that building it's in pretty
good shape
for the most part the parts that have
are not being used and i'm wondering it
would cause any harm if we were to table
this until we got
dcyf's answer and perhaps coordinating
with charlie
i'm sorry i didn't understand that
representative edward's question was
could we use that space for warehouse
space right um i didn't was that
that was what you were implying i i was
more generic in repurposing the building
because it's got specialty spaces that
might be good suitable for a similar use
right i i although the square footage is
you know significant in some areas of
that building i don't believe it would
be conducive to storing equipment there
aren't um elevators that go to the
second floors of some of those areas
there are many you know small rooms um i
i'm not sure that that would make sense
as a warehouse space
i don't think you're going to get a
different answer from anyone else at the
department but
if you want me to
provide it
in writing i can certainly do that my
question is if my question is more than
members of the committee do you think it
would be appropriate
okay
if you want my answer it's no
okay but
uh could i have a motion to approve
fis22113
so moved thank you second
okay
don't all jump at once
representative emmerich
will you please call the roll
okay we'll roll call on 22-11
representative edwards yes
clerk votes yes representative erf yes
representative walner
senator daniels
yes senator gray yes senator gaida no
senator rosenwald yes
representative berger yes
madam chair the voters eight to one
thank you the vote being eight to one
fis-22
is approved
moving now to
fis22116
from the
gopher office
good morning
um
we have some questions on um
this particular item dealing with the
veterans camp
um
i don't like that name i think we ought
to call it the veterans air base
or the veteran's ship i don't know
yeah
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
i i do have a few questions
on this item
my understanding is
we're
not going to own this site easter seals
is
they already own it there's not a
competitive bid
contract
we're
gonna spend 23 million dollars
in a lump sum not specified so my
first question is do you have any kind
of
plan you could share with us
and my second question is
does
this obligate
the state
any state program in any way that's
going to be a budget expense
that we should be thinking about the
ongoing
operational cost or contract cost
um well to answer your question this
request today is the accept and expense
so that we can excuse me would you
identify yourself um i'm sorry taylor
caswell okay executive director of
gopher um no thank you
this is the accept and expense that we
can continue to work with easter seals
on the
final
provisions of this plan
but in concept this is a a project that
will be sort of the crown jewel of
veterans services and housing available
on a single site 15 acres and frank
franklin
that the easter seals does currently
already own
with regard to the competitively bid
component to this
this site is ideal in every way for this
type of a project
any funding that ultimately makes its
way into a contract which would have to
be approved prior to any of this
actually being spent on this project
would still have to comply with all of
the
federal procurement
rules federal environmental rules and so
on that are applicable under the
american rescue plan act
could i follow up please thank you
but
these are essentially state funds
um because we're accepting them
so
what is the state's oversight
going to be on this project
and and then there was the second part
of my question
okay so this i mean my the way that this
would work is that these are federal
arpa funds that we would accept and
spend be available for us to continue uh
to to work with easter seals to make the
final designs on this project which
would ultimately come up with a contract
in which all of those issues would be
addressed prior to any money being spent
and i would say that this is designed to
be funding exclusively for
the development and construction of this
project and would not be used basically
because due to the simple fact that we
can't
obligate funds beyond 24 and spend
beyond 26 that this would all have to be
done within that time frame so it does
not envision in this particular
component of the funding the operational
costs that would go with this and those
would be exclusively on easter seals
for the operation of that project just
as they do you know a lot of other
projects around the state
thank you
are there further questions
senator daniels
thank you
in choosing the the property in which to
put this
camp how do you go about competing with
other projects the state has going on
for instance relocation of sununu center
i'm not sure that there was
an analysis that compared it to that
particular site i think this is
a situation where we have an owner that
um has
that we are well familiar with that has
done housing development and services
for uh for for different types of
populations in the state that owns a
site that meets a lot of the criteria
that you would look for in a site like
this
and so
as i mentioned this would be
a project that ultimately would fall
under all of the federal competitive bid
process for the actual construction of
this project uh should we get to that
point
thank you
if i could so
what what you're saying is that the
the 23 million
will
be spent on the facility
but not until
a contract is approved by gnc correct
okay so you're just getting the money
up front
so that you can
do something with the contract is that
correct well yeah i mean it makes it a
lot easier for easter seals to make
commitments of their time and energy and
resources if they know that the funding
is available for the completion of the
project if it actually you know comes to
that okay thank you
uh representative edward you had a
question uh i withdraw it okay thank you
are there any further questions
move approval okay uh
senator daniels moves approval of
fis 22 116
seconded by senator gaida
will the clerk please call the roll
roll call
22116 representative edwards yes clerk
votes yes representative earth yes
representative walner
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald no
representative umberger yes
and i'm sure the vote is eight to one
okay the vote being eight to one
fis22116
is approved
uh madam chair yes uh may i ask senator
rosenwald no no you can ask it
afterwards it would be fascinating to
know never mind
later
okay
all right now we move to um
commissioner caswell's other hack
which is 22117
department of business and economic
affairs
someone from the senate had some
questions on this okay thank you
senator rosenwald when you get yours yes
i'm at the item thank you and thank you
again for taking my questions
my understanding is that
you want to hire these three
positions to work with the existing
housing
agencies like new hampshire housing
finance authority
i'm wondering first if your intention is
to use
use all of the
housing money to provide workforce
housing and
would that be within the statutory
framework
that the state has
for workforce housing
so in terms of the
prod the programs that
i think the governor referred to
in his state of the state address the
100 million dollar intention on that the
details of those programs
are still being worked out and in fact i
think some of what we're trying to
achieve is to bring in
someone who's going to be ultimately
responsible for potentially running that
program
to assist in the final version of all of
that
i think it's very much the stated
intention of the governor to have this
funding
be focused in the middle income category
there are many different sort of
linguistic gymnastics that people
perform when it comes to affordable
housing
and i think our goal with this will be
to accelerate
and make more efficient the process of
moving as many units as we can with this
with this funding uh the bulk of which
we would uh we would want to see be in
that middle income category
could ask a follow-up thank you and that
leads to my next question of
does bea is it your understanding
that the treasury rule allows
that funding to be used for affordable
housing and not only market rate housing
yes ma'am we would we would be
qualifying this program most likely
under the revenue replacement categories
uh which would allow us to be able to
have some level of flexibility in
getting the funding into those types of
projects thank you
thank you are there any further
questions
seeing none could i have a motion please
to accept fis22117
move to approve
seconded by senator rosenwald and good
luck finding those three people yeah
yeah i know and uh you were another
reason why
commissioner arlinghaus was here because
i'm
i'm very very concerned about
all of these positions that were
approving
month after month after month
so
okay
that's my
i know
roll call on 22117 representative
edwards yes clerk votes yes
representative earth yes
representative walner
senator daniels yes senator gray
yes senator gaida yes senator rosenthal
yes
representative umberger yes madam chair
the vote is nine to zero vote being nine
to zero
fis22117
is approved
madam chair yes
we approved
fis22103 on consent
uh i i had a couple of questions if i if
i could ask them even though it doesn't
won't affect the vote
uh is this something you personally want
to know or is it something the committee
needs to know
i i can't speak for the committee i
think it's it's relevant to this program
though
all right one question
okay so um
so 103 is essentially a a program that
enhances our uh std
monitoring and remediation
and it's it's it's associated with the
fact that because of covid
it implies there's been a surge and so
my question is
do we do we know what the correlation
between stds and covid
is because it i i would think it the
opposite has happened stds have gone
down in social isolation
so i think it would be best to get you
that information where um
the most the public health folks have
left unless you have that
direct information
hi thank you for the record and landry
associate commissioner at dhhs thank you
so much for your question i would agree
with
karen that we can provide that
information in more detail i know
there's a lot going on right now to
update some of our information that's
come in on on std rates
but just tangentially there are some
that have increased but then as you
predicted some took a dip in 2020
because people weren't seeking care
because of the pandemic during you know
the stay at home and and that piece so
now that some of those numbers are
starting to rise as well but as you know
director tilly has all that information
inside and out
and she'd be happy to provide a detail
if we if we can send that to you in
writing
well well thank you for that i
i just uh what my concern there is is
that um we're staffing up for what may
be a period of decline in stds and then
with the covet gone we may expect std
rates to go up and then these positions
are going away so it just seems like our
workload and manpower capacity may be
out of sync here
so again thank you that
completely understand your point so
again with these funds as as director
tilly has explained i think before the
the disease investigation that's
traditionally
done by
those investigating stds is the same
practice that was needed by cobia 19. so
a lot of these funds are allow us to
flex up and down so we can continue our
traditional work around stds and then
as covid variants come in or
come in and out as we see happening you
know throughout the last two years and
as the papers are reporting now this
will give us the flexibility to step up
and down as needed but it won't take
away from our traditional work around
scd investigations
all right thanks for the answer thank
you madam chair yes no problem
okay we now move to tab 11 fis22105
request from the department of
transportation
are they hiding out there
oh
yes you are hiding out there
hello marie mullen with the department
of transportation
okay um
we have to
actually vote on this because it's not
on the consent calendar
are there um
any questions
regarding the transfer of this money
for winter maintenance
we're actually happy that winter
maintenance is almost over
we hope okay seeing none could i have a
motion please
move to approve yes
senator
daniels and senator gray
was that is that correct
okay
will the clerk please call the role or
call 22105.
representative edwards yes
clerk vote chess representative irf yes
representative walner
senator daniels yes senator gray yes
senator gaida yes senator rosenwald yes
representative umberger yes
i'm sure the vote is nine to zero vote
being nine to zero fis 22 105 is
approved and that's probably the easiest
time you will ever have here at fiscal
okay
uh
we we now turn to tab 12.
a request from the uh
judicial council
for uh
2.3 plus million dollars
from funds not otherwise appropriated
pardon me
i'm still alive
good morning madam chair and committee
members i'm sarah blodgett executive
director of the judicial council
with nina gardner the chair of the
judicial council
amazing who shows up right okay are
there any questions uh
for uh
miss blodgett
okay thank you
um can we expect that
these salary increases will be
have to be made permanent
and will be rolled into the next budget
thank you
will it be really temporary thank you
for that question senator rosenwald
this request is is quite unique as i'm
sure all of the committee members see
and one of the reasons that it is so
unique is the recent formation of a
union at the public defender office
and we really have just started that
process
there is no agreement in effect
negotiations have not even begun so our
next request for the upcoming biennium
is going to depend on those union
negotiations so it is certainly possible
that what will be included in our
request but at this point we just can't
say thank you
are there any further questions
uh yes senator daniels thank you for
so for clarification we're using
one-time money
but your answer is you're not sure if
it's going to be for ongoing expenses or
not thank you senator daniels that is
exactly correct okay thank you
are there any further questions
i just have one quick statement that
i think everyone knows the public
defenders are in
very bad shape
not physically but fiscally
and
so
this is extremely important to try to
keep the public defenders we have and
hopefully be able to hire some new
people so thank you madam chair and i
did just want to mention that we have
had incredible support during this
crisis from the governor's office from
the supreme court and from the
department of justice
we're very lucky to have such
wonderful partners in this
thank you
could i have a motion senator rosenwald
second by
representative irf
will the clerk please call the roll
we'll call
22-110 representative edwards yes
torquefocus representative earth yes
representative wallner
senator daniels no
senator gray
yes
senator guida
no senator rosenwald yes
represent yes
madam chair the vote is seven to two
on a vote of seven to two fis 22-110
is approved
thank you very much for coming in thank
you very much madam chair
okay we now turn to the miscellaneous
items
and
um i understand we have a
request from lba to
hire someone
yes
thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh pursuant to the
administrative procedures of fiscal when
the lba wants to the lba office wants to
fill a position they need fiscal
approval we actually had a recent
vacancy we had someone move over to the
department of safety to help out with
road toll
our auditors were able to find someone a
current student at unh uh that is has
agreed to
join our office contingent upon fiscal
approval after graduation in may so we
would ask for your approval to fill that
position
could i have a motion to approve the
hiring of
financial auditor a financial auditor
so moved second second
uh
senator daniels and senator gaida
okay i'm very happy that someone
actually came in with a prospect
prior to
asking for hiring so thank you for that
work and uh if anybody else needs uh
financial auditors out there
you can
chat with um
mr kane and he can give you some
pointers on
how to hire those people so
okay
oh wait we need to vote
for you on roll call
oh i guess we don't need a roll call do
we
it's up to you it can be voice or roll
okay all those in favor please raise
your hand
opposed
motion passes
okay thank you i think there are only
eight of us
okay
the next item
that i do have a question on is the
department of education
on fis-22092
this is um
preventing
childhood lead
poisoning and paint from
water quarterly report blah blah blah
okay um
i read the report
and my only concern is that it doesn't
appear that all schools are cooperating
in
this testing
and i just want to know
a why
and b what are you doing to fix it
sure so for the record my name is amy
clark and i'm with the department of
education in school facilities and i
brought along with brandon kernan hi and
i'm the administrator of the drinking
water groundwater bureau at the
department of environmental services
great okay so we work we work
collaboratively together on this item
obviously
and
the report those it looks like
non-compliance perhaps but it was the
results of the testing that i think that
you're looking at so um
on
that table in appendix a
so keep in mind the standard is at 15
parts per billion which requires schools
to remediate for lead and these are the
results of those samples so what is what
it's saying is 36 percent of the schools
tested exceeded the limits but then they
were required to remediate
um and so we actually have almost 93 of
our schools reporting those results to
us
yeah i got that okay but
what about the seven percent that aren't
reporting and what are you doing to fix
that
sure there's a lot of work ongoing right
now to improve the management of this
program essentially there was a law
passed in 2018 that required these
schools to sample without a system in
place and without a budget in place at
the time we since received epa grants
pretty substantial grants
and
developed work plans that involved
hiring a contractor to administer in
outreach to the schools and also a
temporary part-time position
unfortunately
right when those got approved covet
occurred and there was sort of a freeze
on new contracts and also hiring new
staff until people kind of figured out
the consequences of of covid
at the time
since that time we have hired
the person who's now developed the rfp
we've hired a contractor and they are
now
you know proactively outreaching to
these schools letting them know about
the statutory requirements to sample and
to mitigate if there's exceedances
and so that works on going there's a
database dashboard being developed so
the public in a very transparent way can
see what schools have sampled which ones
have issues and which ones have
addressed the issues and so essentially
there's been a couple year delay but the
program is very much on its way to
gaining compliance
i should note
that
sort of parallel to all that and again
this is largely a lot of outreach and
voluntary compliance with schools
there's not a system in place for
enforcement
there are legislative initiatives
underway that address this area of
stature one is senate bill 452 which is
still in the senate i believe it goes to
finance next and the other is house bill
21 which was heard by the senate
education committee this year
combined they substantially change
what's in the statute essentially create
a pretty um overarching regulatory
process for schools to comply with
and when we talked with the
the comm the education committee this
week
des really painted a picture of what
could happen if both house bill 1421
which seems to have pretty broad support
and senate bill 452 if they in tandem
were both to
pass
one lowers the standard from 15-5 so you
have a lot more non-compliance like
double the number of non-compliance
which might be appropriate but it
creates work
and another provision of one of the
bills house bill 1421 would actually
require that we administer these
requirements and fine people if they
don't comply and so we painted a picture
to the education committee whereby we
would be regulating 1500 entities
between schools and child care
facilities 20 to 30 thousand sampling
points as your every fixture that's
available for drinking water has to be
tested and tracked and just told them
what it would take you know sending out
sampling schedules you know requiring
samples processing samples doing
violations of samples aren't collected
doing violations of you don't mitigate
samples a really big regulatory regime
for entities environmental services
usually don't work with schools that buy
water from a water system so we
suggested that we have a work session
and senator ward's was recepted to that
and asked des to prepare some materials
to look at maybe another path
the thought being that in schools
especially in child care facilities
people aren't going to every single sink
generally to get their drinking water
there's water fountains and bottle fill
up stations
so using available grant programs or to
get more grant funds to maybe establish
a program where schools really focus on
having points of people for people to
get their potable water and that those
be tested and that those bottle phillips
stations be state of the art maybe go
even beyond lead and have ability to
filter other things
as a way to maybe give schools and
shocker facilities a more streamlined
process to make sure their water meets
standards opposed to tracking 20 to 30
000 sampling points at these facilities
where people might not be drinking from
the janitor some faucet or
you know the the sink in the english
room so
uh senator ward just asked us for more
information on other ideas and we're
preparing that this wednesday so both we
have two tracks going one to gain
compliance with the current statute
i guess three tracks three to create a
comprehensive regulatory regime which
des thinks we have a lot of concerns
about and we think regulated entities
will have a lot of concerns about once
if it got into place and then maybe a
third option that's really just focusing
on the points where people drink their
water and making sure that water is
really safe to drink
okay so so is
is that going to
your third point is that going to get
into a amendment
yes i believe that senator ward's
intention she
asked us to combine 1421
house bill 1421 and senate bill 452
which again
when put together have a lot different
effects than
apart and then to work in this third
option as well
so that there's not this whole new
regulatory regime that's created
senator rosenwald
thank you um of the my question is of
the 1.6 million dollars
that we appropriated four years ago now
or three and a half
has only and forty four thousand dollars
been
encumbered
and if so
why so little when a third of the
schools
are testing above the allowable amount
so those numbers are correct a lot a
large part of it has to do with one
there's been no system in place and no
staffing in place until the last six
months really to reach out to schools
and connect them
with the results and to the available
funds
another option might be that
these are fixtures that aren't really
used for potable water and so they put
up a sign instead of
applying for a five thousand dollar
grant or something to mitigate it
the data you see here is pretty coarse
what we really can't connect those
results to is exactly how often those
sources are being used for drinking
water at this point and that's what's
being fixed with trupani the contractor
that's now been hired and then the
temporary part-time position
the data is going to mean a lot more
over the next year and you're going to
see a lot more use of those funds
and we may go back to the trust fund and
ask them to
change those parameters to also allow
child care facilities to be eligible
because they have to comply with this
requirement right now only schools can
and maybe to even entertain these bottle
fill up stations you know focus points
of drinking water opposed to mitigating
only fixtures that are over the action
level
uh
representative emrick
thank you madam chair
would i be naive to think that a
town i live in hampton
we have a private water but if for the
whole town would i be naive to think
that if you just tested the water
supplier you wouldn't need to test every
location in every school
for most contaminants your suggestion is
correct but not for lead lead is a
plumbing based contaminant it comes from
the pipes and so or fixtures okay thank
you
yes represent edwards uh thank you madam
chair
as i understand it we have a compliance
problem with
children being tested for lead poisoning
you may know that there's two age points
where they're supposed to get lead
tested and and one is earl very early
after they've been born the other ones i
guess before they go into the school
system
are
are you the right people to to work with
the doe
to develop an educational program for
parents intended for parents so that
parents know why they should
seek out lead poison testing for their
children or who who might be accountable
for developing testing that would make
our
public smarter about why we want them
tested
the department of health hume services
has a whole program that oversees the
childhood testing and so i don't know if
anyone here is able to speak to that
from hhs but certainly that agency that
takes the lead and they they collaborate
with us you know to extend they have a
child with high blood levels they'll
work with us to get the water tested and
i'm sure if it's a school concern they
work with department of education but
they're definitely the lead
and i just i just want to say with the
commissioner of education in here one
proposal that we have in legislation is
to expect the schools to be more of an
enforcer on parental compliance with
lead testing and and i'd much rather see
us go down the education role than the
coercion rule
well that's why they're getting canva
sorry
okay are there any further i had no idea
this was going to open up so much
information
when i
asked my
question but i really thank you for that
and uh and for your work and i know that
sometimes
getting um
non-state agencies to cooperate and
to
to do the things they need to do
is is difficult so
keep on them
okay thank you
oh
i'm sorry yes go ahead pull your
microphone closer
my first question is how do they
remediate this because there's miles and
miles of plumbing in these schools
and do do they go through you
to get a grant
to remediate the problem
to remediate the problems with several
options you can often replace an older
fixture
older plumbing components are allowed to
have more lead in the wetted area of the
fixture so that could be an option
you could also put an inline filter
that removes the lead as well
and then yes there is right now a grant
program that pays 50 of the remedial
costs for schools not for child care
facilities and the department of
education administers that the
administration thank you very much
okay
thank you
oh wait we've got one more question
thank you madam chair
can you
clarify whether there's any legislation
coming forward to add child care
facilities to this program
it's already there the statute requires
child care facilities sample but they
don't have access to the 1.6 million
dollar grant right now
from the trust fund and so yeah we are
working to find options it could be that
we go back to the trust fund which is
legislators and appointments members of
the public
or potentially there's arpa dollars
allocated for drinking water that we
might be able to use and then even
health and human services have some
options and they're the ones that
oversee child care facilities that might
be able to help with that
so is there any legislation coming
forward
to address the fact that they can't
access these funds the drinking water
funds
i not at this time i don't think the
mechanism is necessarily a legislative
action though i think it's
tweaking or making decisions with
available funds thank you
okay can we move on
all right thank you very much
um
the governor's office for emergency
relief and recovery
um
is
provided us last month with
the status of cares funding
and this month
he's going to talk to us they're going
to talk to us
about
what goes on with our
has gone on with arpa
welcome back
happy to be here
i knew it
getting nice outside i think yeah
again good afternoon everybody i think
we wanted to
come back last month we got a chance to
talk a little bit about cares act and
sort of where
things stood with that i wanted to come
back today and give you sort of an
update on where things stand with the
arpa funding and
in particular uh the portion that gopher
has some a good degree of involvement
with which is with the state and local
fiscal recovery fund dollars which i can
get into it a little bit more
as we go along here
um
a couple of things first uh
with regard to dates and importance and
timeline because this is obviously
setting a little bit of the stage for
where we are with uh with arpa
um and again
and i'll mention this again later
probably is the fact that this is a
program that is fundamentally different
from the cares act cares act funds were
really there for relief purposes
these funds have been provided
in the context of recovery and if you
sort of take a moment to think about
what that distinction is it does help
drive
uh some of the types of projects that
we're seeing coming through and that you
all are seeing as as they get to you
um
the american rescue plan was signed into
law just about a year ago march 11th of
and then subsequently in may of 2021 we
got what's called the interim final rule
which was a document of about 40 or 50
pages that gave us a good sense in terms
of where the general
funding should be used how it should be
used
different buckets and expenditure
categories were provided
and laid for sort of the reporting
requirements that we're going to go with
these resources
we have we've been and we continue to
operate under the ifr
in uh january of this year
uh treasury came back with
the the uh no longer interim final rule
but the final final final rule
and that uh document uh exceeds for
400 pages uh and gave us a significant
significantly more detailed
sense of where these
funds
how they expect us to report and the
data that they need in order to
complete the program and so on and so
forth and we've spent a good amount of
time going through all of those and
i will say that you know in the most
part that's a lot of what you see coming
to you are
projects that are fitting these
increasingly new
categories and
reporting requirements
and lastly of course as you all know
quite well
there are two important dates with all
arpa projects in that
the first is december 31st 2024 that's
the date by which we have to obligate
these resources under fiscal recovery
fund
and then december 31st 2026 which is the
point at which we have to have spent
all of those resources
again going as i mentioned the state and
local fiscal recovery fund
this is one portion of the american
rescue plan funds that have come to new
hampshire
i
mentioned that we are certainly subject
to all the federal regulations under
this program the total
that uh has been designated by the fed
federal government under again fraf
is specifically nine hundred ninety four
million five hundred and fifty five
thousand eight hundred and seventy eight
dollars
um
and uh we are i think
in your documents that we provided it
gives you an update as to where we stand
in the
obligation of those resources
at this point
a lot of the
major requirements that i mentioned
under
under the federal guidance under federal
rules
defines specifically the types of
eligibilities they generically fall
under categories like public health
negative economic impacts and
infrastructure
everything that we provide and
everything that um that we end up uh
getting approval to move forward with
has to fall in and align with these
expenditure categories that are lined
out in the final rule
uh i would also mention that in every
case
these funds well it
in some cases it depends on the level of
the expenditure but in almost all cases
federal procurement rules
are required to be followed as our
federal labor laws things like davis
bacon
and environmental
rules all need to be complied with by
the end user of these projects of these
pro funds i should say
and i did mention the deadlines that
shows up many times here in my notes
gopher's responsibility primarily in a
lot of cases has been
both to do the reporting and the data
analysis and
all of the required submissions to the
federal government
but we also work very closely with all
other state agencies and with
other recipients of these resources
on a regular basis to make sure that the
data they're collecting is adequate and
it's going to meet the reporting
requirements and
there's a lot of work that goes into
that end of the business
as i mentioned there are a number of
programs that that you are seeing
requests for as we go through here that
are not specifically
under the state and local
federal recovery funds
um i thought i'd mention a couple of
those
um the rental assistance program that
we've talked about many times is
separate from that
the capital project funds
which
we will start seeing some more activity
over the next couple of months this is
primarily the broadband
funding that is available that total uh
allocated to new hampshire that we have
not
yet deployed uh is uh 122 million
dollars under the capital project fund
again that's separate from these frf
dollars
the housing assistance fund
this is program that we talked about i
think just a few weeks ago and is just
now getting started up uh to assist
for homeowners as opposed to rentals
and then it also does not include
all the funding that will start flowing
under the infrastructure
bill that congress passed subsequently
and that's
obviously going to be run primarily with
the department of transportation so as
that money starts to flow i imagine
we'll see
commissioner sheehan here more regularly
as well
uh and of course hhs
uh has uh also seen a significant amount
of resource that they're putting for
toward a number of different obvious
public health and health related and
vaccine programs
on the where we are right now of course
i i we provided you the most recent
update as to the list of the
programs that have been
obligated and approved here at joint
fiscal committee
they're really falling into a number of
pretty large categories there's
obviously the water and sewer
infrastructure that was done pretty
early on then most of that at least
under frf is being run by
department of environmental services
those funds as you'll recall we moved
pretty quickly just because of the time
horizon that is necessary for those
types of projects and you know that we
do have to have this money spent by 2026
which seems like a long way away unless
you're
trying to permit and move a lot of these
projects all at the same time
mental and behavioral health obviously
continues to be an area where you're
seeing a lot of these programs
the covet 19 response
at least so far has been a continuing
number we hope that we're going to
continue to see those numbers start to
fall off a little bit and then of course
in the economic
relief and development area
gopher is in the context of in addition
to all the reporting that goes on we
spend a significant amount of time
reviewing proposals from different
agencies and from other parties around
eligibility and the cost of those
programs and looking for areas where
there may be duplication and overlap
among existing programs that we seek to
avoid
as you've heard me say many times the
primary function and purpose of these
dollars hopefully in most cases is to be
able to make those like one-time
investments
in um initiatives and programs and
infrastructure that are going to carry
us forward
for a long period of time and not
necessarily get the state into a
position where we're going to have
ongoing operational costs as a result of
these investments
and of course as you well know
everything that ends up making its way
through that process
we end up talking about in one form or
another here in this forum so
um
i i
that's that's kind of where we are right
now um
uh
and uh of course i'm always
any questions that you might have and i
just wanted to say uh you know we
certainly appreciate all of you working
on these items as they come through on a
regular basis
and really appreciate all the time that
you're putting into taking a look at
what we've what we've been able to do at
least thus far
are there any questions yes senator
daniels
thank you
in addition to the mandates that come
from epa regarding water and waste water
are there any other
mandates that opera money could could
cover
i guess
are you talking about
regulatory mandates that right i'm
saying like in in our town you know
we're looking at eight to ten million
dollars worth of federal mandates
that that are placed on us for water or
wastewater
and uh
so i'm just i'm always looking just
at what the federal government is
placing on us for mandates and asking
you know uh are they supplying the money
well in this case here some of the money
is being supplied and we may be able to
use
that water and wastewater
money that comes in to take care of some
of those mandates but on the other
categories that you have identified i'm
wondering if there are any other
mandates in there that we could go back
and tell our constituents we've got
federal money that's going to cover that
well i guess it would be hard to say
without
knowing specifically uh the case but i
but i guess what i would say senator is
that
we are not seeing that there is
necessarily relief from those federal
mandates in the use of these funds
so in those instances where des is
having to
move these resources out into our
communities for water and sewer
upgrades or projects
we continue to have the same
requirements and permitting requirements
that are required both by the state and
federal government
in fact you might recall i think we had
an item
some time ago for des to add staff
for
the permitting office specifically for
that purpose and that this was going to
generate some additional pressure on
that office
to uh to move those projects quickly
thank you
are there any further questions yeah yes
representative walner
thank you
i did notice in a
in a couple of categories
um
there are
you refer to personnel cost um can you
talk a little bit about
how you're
using these dollars
around personnel i know
the workforce is is really
an issue for so many areas
well i mean leaving the workforce issue
aside and finding people to fill these
positions which is
another issue
that um
i know you've talked about already today
um i was going to ask michael caine
where he was getting his person from you
know how much are you paying them
[Music]
um but to your question all of the all
of the requests that are coming through
for these types of funds for
uh for staffing my department my other
department included are for 90 positions
so these are temporary jobs that are
tied to the funding um that ultimately
they'll be dealing with so the intention
is not to necessarily
extend beyond the life of the arpa funds
with these dollars for the temporary
staff that typically is coming
in front of you
a follow-up yes please i was looking at
one it was uh it's on um
the
appendix too
it's the wage enhancement for
the um licensing of nursing assistants
and i was wondering about that kind of a
program and how that that kind of
program is working oh i'm trying to
remember that would you mind just
mentioning the item you're looking at
um it's
wage enhancement for licensed nursing
assistants l
lnas
do you wanna i can talk about it yeah
chase hageman deputy director at gopher
um so that's probably a poor
characterization of what that program
did it was actually a
an amount of money given per bed at that
facility the facility could then use
as it needed and it may have used it for
assisting with wages to retain or
acquire staff
thank you
are there any further questions
okay i do have a i have a further
question
um i'm looking at your first page that's
got the little blue thing
and it's showing that we have uh
497 million dollars left
and we have
four years to allocate it
and spend it
yes
2026. yeah so
when are we going to
gets
something
[Music]
on the other
497 million
i mean we're chipping away at it but
i think like today would we have uh
23 million that that doesn't chip away
very much
so
and
it's not as easy to spend a billion
dollars as you might think but i i you
know my my concern is okay that as we
start getting into um
you know budget season next year and all
of the
mess that goes along with that that uh
you know we on the uh
physical committee are basically all
tied up in that stuff and uh
and i know that you know the
people
um
in the uh
various departments are starting to
think about preparing budgets and
you know i just i i'm just concerned
that
we need to
try to figure out how to spend it
quicker where you know where we are and
and i guess if um
i could say if anybody has any wonderful
ideas they can either um
talk to uh commissioner caswell or
myself but uh
you know i just you understand where i'm
coming from yes ma'am
and uh it's and no we cannot give it to
each one of us for
enhanced salary for our positions
i've already tried that yeah
good okay
are there any even if we doubled it i'm
not sure that would spend much man
[Music]
[Laughter]
i think you're right are there any yes
uh
representative walner you're looking for
the pay raise
no i'm looking not looking for the pay
raise i think we're paid adequately here
100 every year
um i was wondering
so you're setting aside money for each
of these projects
i'm sorry i'm you're setting aside money
for each of these projects or funds for
each of these projects but as we get
closer to
some of these projects probably won't
spin down
all that you set aside yep so there will
be some funds left will the federal
government allow us to have any access
to that
those funds after 2026. i'm not sure
there's been a official answer to that
question but to your point
in a lot of cases particularly in the
larger number cases that we know are
going to go on for a period of time we
actually build in a
an expiration date in the contracts
well before we get to the end
with the ability to extend but it gives
us that opportunity to make sure that
we're not just leaving everything until
december 30th 2026 and saying let's see
how much we got left i mean we don't
want to be in that position
so um yeah we're very cognizant of that
and
under very specific orders to make sure
we don't leave any money on the table if
we can
that's why we had that cares act thing
that you know the waterfall yeah we got
a little close to the end on that
yeah and uh making sure that we got that
money approved that was like an eight
month program remember initially i know
yeah we already didn't have a lot of
time for that money
okay
thank you very much i appreciate it and
uh i know that if anyone has any
questions i can always give you a call
absolutely okay thank you thank you i
would like to point out
just
before we have just a couple things to
finish up
but
we are
going to be asking the departments to
come in
and talk to us about their
arpa funds that have not come through
gopher
and there are lots and lots and lots of
dollars out there
and uh we're going to be starting next
month
with hhs and des
coming in to uh to talk to us about that
because i think that you know we as the
keeper of the dollar so to speak
need to be sure that we are holding our
folks responsible for that money
so we'll see what happens um you know
but we'll we'll rotate it around so that
every department that's received
offline arpa money i know that's the
wrong term but
other arpa money
um will be in to see us so
look looking
so looking forward to that
time
all right
well we'll see what happens
okay
um let's see
i think our our
i think our next thing is um audits
is that correct
yes yes
always our favorite time
oh it's true excuse me ours two manager
good afternoon members of the committee
for the record steve smith director of
audits um
and uh with me here our first report is
the lottery
okay
and kim bisson
is going to present the management
letter as a result of our financial
statement audit for fiscal 21
and joining me is uh
director mcintyre and jim durst the cfo
for any questions that the committee may
have
good morning madam chair and members of
the committee again for the record my
name is kimberly bisson i'm here today
to present the management letter which
is a byproduct of our audit of the
lottery's fiscal year 2021 financial
statements which were previously
presented to this committee at the
january 21st meeting
if you turn to the table of contents you
will see that the report includes three
internal control comments one of which
is considered to be a material weakness
the lottery concurs with all three
comments and none suggests legislative
action is required
the observations begin on page three
observation number one discusses several
deficiencies in internal control which
combine to result in a material weakness
in the lottery sports betting revenue
and contract monitoring processes
to address this we recommend that
lottery take steps to formally document
its policies and procedures covering the
major areas of its sports betting
operations and to amend its contract to
require the sports betting vendor obtain
a service organization control report
specific to new hampshire lottery on an
annual basis
we also recommend that lottery implement
policies and procedures to assess risks
related to outsourced services including
identifying when service organization
control reports should be written into
lottery contracts
turning to page seven
observation number two recommends the
lottery enhance its financial accounting
and reporting staff by establishing a
director of finance or similar position
in order to support the ever-increasing
scope and complexity in lottery
operations and to mitigate the risk of
relying on the performance of one
employee for all financial accounting
and reporting activities
additionally lottery should take steps
to formally document policies and
procedures that address the significant
aspects of its financial reporting
process
including but not limited to the
development of significant accounting
estimates completion of monthly
reconciliations preparation of year-end
adjusting and accrual entries and the
compilation of its annual comprehensive
financial report
finally observation number three
beginning on page nine recommends that
the lottery is administratively attached
council for responsible gambling
implement formal policies and procedures
to ensure all invoices are adequately
supported in accordance with contracted
terms and ensure duties within the
council are appropriately segregated to
allow for an independent review of
invoices prior to submission to the
lottery commission for payment
it should be noted that the council also
concurred with this comment
the appendix located behind the tab on
page 11 reports the current status as of
december 16 2021 of observations
contained in the fiscal year's 2020 and
lottery commission management letters as
noted at the bottom of page
13. seven comments were resolved one was
in the process of remediation and one
remains unresolved
page 14
reports the current status of fiscal
year 2019 comments resulting from the
work of an i.t specialist engaged to
perform a review of lottery's i.t
systems as noted at the bottom of the
page two comments were resolved and two
are in the process of remediation
this concludes my presentation i would
like to thank executive director
mcintyre and lottery staff for their
assistance and cooperation during the
audit
and with your permission i will now turn
the presentation over to lottery
excuse me
thank you and good afternoon um my name
is charlie mcintyre i'm the privilege of
being the director of new hampshire
lottery
and with me is our chief financial
officer jim doris as
previously noted i'd like to thank the
folks at the lba staff as always
a thorough audit and the recommendations
they have
forwarded are already being implemented
as we speak so
happy to answer any questions you might
have
does anyone have any questions
the only question i have is
do we get feedback on
when these things are corrected
um we'll certainly uh there we're on it
every year and so they'll be back
probably next month or
so i always say i'm going to miss if you
never leave um and i may say that
kiddingly
but certainly they'll be back in june to
for their audit and so like our example
the sock 2 report request um i've
already signed an agreement with
draftkings they'll have that it's
already being implemented as we speak so
um
as you can see three findings is not bad
and one of them is not me or us really
so i think two is pretty good but yeah
if you wanted a separate update madam
chair happy to do that for you
but they they're back in june so um
they'll keep tabs on us yeah i guess we
just yeah and and maybe you know i don't
i don't need anything really formal i
just want to make sure that
on each of the audits that we are
making progress and not just letting it
hang around
yes but if i may man i'm chair um as you
know we we audit the lottery commission
every year right so you have three years
worth of observations in front of you
with the status of them
so for example the
2019 when we come back in for the fiscal
22 audit excuse me yeah fiscal 22 audit
if not if if if those remain unresolved
more than likely they're going to make
it into the body of the
management letter next year so we
we might we we evaluate as what the
status is based on working with the
commit with the
commission
um so
in this particular case
we won't let them just
fall away without
well so you know because there was one
one that you just said
you know hadn't
nothing had been done on it
and uh
that was from what two years ago or
something
a year ago
yes it actually was specifically to a
our sports betting vendor partner not
providing a sock to report um i signed
an agreement uh a change order with them
i think in january so going forward
we'll be getting that
every year so that's the one that was
unresolved and that had to do with
um draftkings changed out a significant
portion of its business it had
previously contracted for
market creation services through a
company called camby they ended up
buying a company called sb tech so they
you know they changed out the
transmission while the car was still
running essentially so
getting a stock to report previously
wouldn't make sense okay thank you all
right
appreciate it and uh keep up the good
work and uh keep sending money to the
education trust fund doing our best
thank you members of the committee
our next management letters for the uh
liquor commission
and uh joining me from our office is jim
le riviere he was the manager on this
and get this audit this year
and joining us from the commission is uh
chairman malika and tina demers
cfo
good morning madam chair and members of
the committee again for the record my
name is jim lariviere
we are here to present the management
letter a byproduct of our audit of the
liquor commission's fiscal year 2021
financial statements which were
previously presented to the committee at
the january 21st meeting
if you turn to the table of contents you
will see that the report includes one
internal control comment classified as a
significant deficiency
the commission concurs with the comment
and no legislative action is required
relative to this comment
the observation on page three
identified where significant errors
detailed in items numbers one and two of
the observation were made
detected and corrected but lacked
documentation explaining the cause of
the errors and the adjustments made to
correct system accounting records
and lacked evidence of management's
review and approval
we recommend the commission establish
formal policies and procedures for
adjusting system accounting records
the policies and procedures should
detail the processes to be performed who
performs each process
and adequate and addresses adequately
documenting the error and corrective
actions
all adjustments should be reviewed and
approved by an appropriate level of
management
independent of the posting and
correction process
the appendix located behind the tab on
page five reports the current status
as of december 17
2021 of the observations contained in
the fiscal year 2020 and fiscal year
liquor commission management letters
as noted at the bottom of page 8
10 comments were fully resolved and
eight comments were in the process of
remediation
this concludes my presentation
i'd like to thank chairman mulika and
chief financial officer tina demers and
the liquor commission staff for their
assistance and cooperation throughout
the audit
with your permission madam chair i'd
like to now turn the presentation over
to the liquor commission's chairman
chairman malika
before you do that can i just ask a
question on the finding certainly um
you show two examples here of one of 48
million and the other one of 1.4 million
and then you recommend that
every error should have some sort of
supervisory signature on it
and
i don't know
i don't know that we
i would hope that
we would give the
liquor commission
people
some sort of
author you know without going up the
chain
for
you know
some amount of money
that you know there's an air you know i
mean it could be a typo you know it
could be
something else but
i i would certainly think that
you know if if i made a thousand dollar
error
that i caught at the end of the month i
should be able to fix that without going
three steps up in supervision
where if over time
i find that i've got
a 1.4 million dollar thing then yes i
think we need to
we need to check that out
and figure out what's going on in our
processes
so
i just asked that the comment that says
everything needs to be approved that
we look at we just look at that between
the
the two of you
to figure out what does that really mean
because i don't think we want to do a 25
error
okay
for you know for so
that
that's dealing with the audit
and you know what what you've come up
with so thank you and i'll let you guys
work it out
okay whatever it is
okay
all right thank you
please
good morning madam chair members of the
committee for the record joseph malika
chairman of the new hampshire liquor
commission and cfo tina demers is with
me as well today i'd like to thank the
lba for their fine work they've always
done a great job and we appreciate them
coming in and looking at our
organization to make sure that it's
running properly
but uh jim and steve and
we appreciate their work
most importantly i'd like to note that i
appreciate the work that tina our cfo
and her staff does
because in in 19 we had 12 observations
and today we only have one and that's
due to the work of that
tina's organization and everyone that
works for tina i just like to have that
on record
thank you madam chair absolutely and i
have one request
from you
um
i don't know exactly when i was reading
it or where i was reading it but uh
it um
in your audit it says everything is
being fixed by the risk management plan
and i would like a copy of that risk
management plan
so that
we can
you know we can see
where that's going and i just
that's all absolutely i'll be happy to
provide that to you all right thank you
thank you very much thank you
okay
you're done
everybody's done
including us no okay
representative emmerich
madam chair i would move to accept both
audits place them on file and released
to the public in the usual manner
do i have a second
thank you senator daniels all those in
favor
aye opposed all right motion passes
now
they tell me
that i'm supposed to set the next
meeting
is that the last thing i have to do yes
which i forget to do most of the time
so
uh
looking at what we normally do um
our next meeting would be on april 15th
which is tax day
and i know everyone has
done their taxes
so uh except for me
so
without any uh
objection or whatever we'll plan on it
for
april 15th
of
whenever april 15th
so is there any other business to be
brought before the meeting
seeing none can i just adjourn there you
go thank you very much
okay
why
there's that report you just
yeah thank you very much
i know you got you got word of this
ahead of time
but i i really do appreciate it
i'll swap you
oh i'll take that
i've got the i've got the uh
for the meeting at 1 30.
you